A couple of weeks ago, we had a reporter come into our home
to learn more about our family and business.
We thought the interview went really well,
very similar to the dozens of interviews we had done in recent memory.
We were taken back, however,
when we saw the printed article,
which shocked us and shocked the world
by being an attack on our family and my marriage,
portraying me as oppressed with my husband being the culprit.
This couldn't be further from the truth.
Nothing we said in the interview implied this conclusion,
which leads me to believe the angle taken was predetermined.
For Daniel and I, our priority in life is god and family.
Everything else comes second.
The greatest day of my life was when Daniel and I were married
13 years ago.
Together, we have built a business from scratch.
We've brought eight children into this world
and have prioritized our marriage all along the way.
We are co parents, co CEOs,
co diaper changers, kitchen cleaners,
and decision makers. We are one,
and I love him more today than I did 13 years ago.
We have many dreams still to accomplish.
We aren't done having babies.
We are excited for our new farm store to open,
and I can't wait to see what the future holds for the rest of it.
But for now, I'm doing what I love most
being a mother, wife,
a businesswoman, a farmer,
a lover of Jesus, and making Meals from scratch